on this Sunday night protecting Hawaii's
Heritage the scramble to save Hawaiians
and preserve their history after the
worst U.S wildfire in 140 years it's a
really historical place
more Wildfire fears in Canada as BC
braces for a heat wave
two years under the Taliban Afghan women
Mark the somber anniversary with a plea
for help
plus remembering Robbie I'll always be
grateful that Robbie saw something to me
a conversation with the oscar-winning
filmmaker who focused his lens on Robbie
Roberts
global national with foreign reporting
tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin with the awful aftermath of
the fires in Maui the death toll now at
93 making it Hawaii's deadliest disaster
and one of the worst wildfires in U.S
history
Crews have surged only a fraction of
that hellish landscape where some
evacuees are now returning to find homes
reduced to Ash hundreds remain missing
and of the Dead just two victims have
been identified
The Remains were fighting
is through a fire that
melted metal
so when we pick up the remains and they
fall apart
that's what you're stepping on
I don't know how much more you want me
to describe it that's what you're
stepping on
beyond that tragic loss of life many
historic and sacred sites were also
engulfed by the blaze a major blow to
Hawaii's Heritage our nuthugarcha is in
Maui with more on those concerns hi Nita
so what are you hearing from people
there
islands and displaced by the Maui fires
have already reported offers from buyers
looking to purchase their property and
there are fears of what that could mean
for the preservation of culture and
Heritage sites in historic Lahaina well
we're grateful that we also have family
nearby but not everybody does and Shalia
keahi is Polynesian her husband is
indigenous to Hawaii their home burned
in the Maui Wildfire but it's the loss
of sacred land in Lahaina the first
capital of the Kingdom of Hawaii that
makes her emotional it's a really
historical place it's where you you know
a lot of things happen a lot of Firsts
happened you know first school First
Capital you know she's a pastor at
King's Cathedral Church in Lahaina it
also burned all right there you go thank
you guys
keoki is now supporting others who lost
everything at another church housing
hundreds of evacuees and taking in
donations from across the island
helicopters filled with food clothing
and other items have been landing on the
fields just outside the church a tourist
destination did get decimated but our
home
directly connected to the importance of
our history has also been decimated
a master teacher of Hawaiian dance known
as akumuhula was part of an annual event
for a local non-profit this weekend
typically held under the now burned
historic Banyan Tree
[Music]
several concerns about the road ahead
now exposed are dozens of archaeological
sites that haven't seen the light of day
in in decades there is a possibility of
it these lands now because there's
nothing on them being sold to
International entities which removes it
further from us from from the native
people of this place they will not take
care of our sights the way that we will
fearing further displacement from their
ancestral homelands which has been going
on for decades there are more native
Hawaiians that live outside of Hawaii
than living in Hawaii you know you hear
the phrase being priced out of paradise
that we're not able to live
unfortunately on our traditional
Homeland
lahaina's Hawaiian language education
preschool was lost in The Inferno there
are growing calls to prioritize its
reconstruction to help ensure the
language isn't lost with it it's really
impactful for the community and and a
big loss
Cody pueo Pata who you heard from in
that story says this weekend's benefit
event was for the Hawaii Community
Foundation which has raised more than 17
million dollars for people affected by
the fires but there are still challenges
getting those resources to where they're
needed most because sell and power
service is still down in those areas
Jeff you through garcha in Maui tonight
thanks nithu
[Music]
here at home BC is bracing for a
dangerous heat wave that could
deteriorate conditions and cause
wildfires there to flare temperatures
are expected to soar into the high 30s
in some areas and last until Thursday
in Ottawa a crowd marched on Parliament
Hill for the rights of people in
Afghanistan this week marks two years
since kabul's violent fall to Taliban
forces that takeover has proved
particularly devastating for women and
girls as Taria Israel reports protesters
are calling for action
gathering in a public place they are
targeted in all species and all walks of
life we the Taliban is trying to erase
women and girls from society but this
crowd is refusing to let them disappear
demonstrators want the United Nations to
declare what's happening in Afghanistan
a gender apartheid this circumstance for
Afghanistan people are really
uh like a nightmare and especially for
women journalist farida nexad escaped
with her daughter a month after the fall
of Kabul
is doing her master's degree at Carleton
while her 14 year old is getting ready
for high school had they stayed in
Afghanistan neither mother nor daughter
would have been able to pursue their
education I'm thinking why my my country
goes all like uh upsets and crying and
begging their fundamental rights the
demonstrators gathered here believe
Canada has a role to play in
highlighting the plight of Afghan women
and their responsibility the largest
human rights violation happens in the
other part of the world that we would
involved for to to two decades and then
we left they are intentionally and
legally wiping out women from the public
life wiped out with a series of
Relentless edicts suffocating every
dimension of women's lives if the
International Community is not going to
take
women's rights seriously there that
means all right as women are as
disposable in the women here want Ottawa
to put more pressure on the United
Nations and the international criminal
court to try the Taliban for crimes
against humanity those people left
behind in Afghanistan we are still with
them standing with them after two years
of feeling ignored Korea isri Global
News Ottawa
and later in the newscast shogufa donish
looks at the ongoing fight to bring
Afghan refugees here to Canada
turning now to tensions over Ukraine the
Russian Navy says it fired warning shots
at a neutral Merchant vessel in the
Black Sea before then boarding it as
Redmond Shannon reports this comes after
Moscow ended a deal that had allowed
Ukraine to export grain by sea
Ukrainian troops installing a new border
post on the Strategic snake island in
the Black Sea it was famously
temporarily captured by Russia last year
this footage released amid a new
escalation in the conflict elsewhere in
the Black Sea the Russian Navy says it
fired warning shots beside a neutral
cargo ship near Turkish waters before
briefly boarding it to inspect its
contents Moscow says the Cirque okan was
on its way to the small Ukrainian Port
of Ismail shipping data says it was
bound for a Romanian port
since Russia ended the Black Sea Green
initiative last month Moscow has ordered
strikes on the primary port city of
Odessa drone attacks hit Ismail 2 after
other Merchant ships prepared to pick up
grain there certainly the Russians have
feared that this is what the Ukraine
players going to be to bust the blockade
analyst Professor Scott Lucas says it's
accepted that warring Nations can
inspect neutral vessels however there's
an easy political and legal answer here
which is Russia's never declared war on
ucraft for Ukraine exporting by ship is
much cheaper than complex land routes so
ships being prepared to run the Black
Sea Gauntlet could be key to the
viability of its grain exports Redmond
Shannon Global News London
Donald Trump could be just days away
from his fourth indictment this one
hinges on whether Trump tried to
overturn the results of the 2020
presidential election in Georgia is
Kamal caramale reports Trump's legal
troubles aren't hurting the former
president's popularity
Donald Trump met with cheers at the Iowa
State Fair Saturday
despite his growing legal troubles which
soon may include a fourth indictment
already Fulton County district attorney
Fannie Willis is expected to seek
charges against Trump and his allies
related to efforts to overturn the 2020
election results in Georgia two
witnesses Georgia's former lieutenant
governor and an independent journalist
confirmed they've been called to appear
before a grand jury in Atlanta Tuesday
the Capstone of this investigation was a
phone call that Donald Trump made with
several of his aides including Mark
Meadows
a couple of days before January 6th
trying to get the Georgia Secretary of
State Brad raffensberger to find quote
780 votes prosecutors are reportedly in
possession of text messages and emails
directly connecting members of Trump's
legal team to the early January 2021
voting system breach in Coffee County
according to CNN Trump took to social
media Sunday calling Willis phony fawnee
defending himself after earlier telling
reporters we don't take plea deals
because I did nothing wrong the former
president already faces federal charges
in the special counsel's January 6th and
classified documents probes as well as
the Manhattan District Attorney's hush
money case but his legal woes don't seem
to be affecting his bid for the White
House
still the most popular Republican and if
he's convicted even on one of them and
he becomes president what does that say
about the voters of the United States
and what kind of impact would it have on
Democracy in America Kamal karamali
Global News
remembering a pride Pioneer coming up a
look back at North America's first
same-sex civil union
foreign
Tebow part of North America's first
same-sex civil union has died Tebow
passed away Friday at the age of 77
after a long battle with Parkinson's he
and his partner spent half a century
together and had just celebrated their
21st wedding anniversary as Felicia
Perillo reports the pair spent a
lifetime fighting for their rights
I cannot compare him that he will be
gone you know it's strange for tail
Waters to speak of his husband
in the past tense it's only been two
days since he passed away
are known for becoming the first
same-sex couple to be legally joined by
civil union in Quebec two years before
the province would legalize same-sex
marriage
in an interview with global news last
year on their 20th wedding anniversary
the couple said they had no idea their
Union would draw the attention that it
did they were the first couple who can
be
having a civil union in Quebec Canada in
USA is part of the history of our
community the couple is also well known
for their decades-long battle against
homophobia over the course of their 50
years together they've been the subject
of homophobic slurs insults and threats
with new numerous cases being heard
before the Quebec human rights tribunal
the most recent one was settled this
past spring one of the most touching
experiences that this year is that
basically Jose was not well he was in a
wheelchair but he insisted being part of
the mediation process at the Human
Rights Commission Office Wilder says he
hopes Tebow will be remembered for his
courage to stand up and fight against
homophobia in hopes that Fight Continues
with the Next Generation and for those
to come
Felicia Perillo Global News Montreal
still ahead Afghan anguish the fight to
bring refugees to Canada two years since
the Taliban takeover
welcome back this week marks two years
since the Taliban took control of
Afghanistan and since then women's
rights have disappeared Afghanistan is
the only country where girls can't go to
secondary school this week Global News
is highlighting stories of Afghans
struggling to survive and to start over
shogufadonish begins our series on life
under the Taliban
thousands of Afghan who flee the Taliban
Now call Canada home
is one of them
but life in a new country can be lonely
much trouble was a former persecutor for
the Afghan government
she was in the office when the Taliban
fighters stormed Cobble Marshall I was
hiding for two three months and after
that by help of some foreign
organization I was evacuated to Abu
Dhabi I really missing my mom my
favorite now lives in Ottawa but without
her parents they are trapped in
Afghanistan their life is not safe so I
cannot I cannot
be happy here she's trying to bring her
mother and father here but keeps hitting
red teeth mustaba wonders if reuniting
would be easier if they were from
Ukraine they forgot Afghan people they
forgot the Afghan cases
since the Russian invasion last year
more than 171
000 ukrainians have arrived in Canada in
the past two years 36 000 Afghan
refugees have come here team leader
served in Afghanistan in 2008 and now
advocates for Afghans who helped the
Coalition he fear they are being
forgotten there's two different programs
two different standards completely
um you know we can all sort of wonder
why that is immigration Minister Mark
Miller defended his government's
response to the crisis there is more
permanence and potential to establish a
life in a new country that these Afghan
refugees benefit from whereas the
welcome of Ukrainian refugees well some
of them may
eventually become Canadians is temporary
in nature
tries to bring the Comforts of home here
but says there is no replacement for
being with her family when I talked with
my mom most time we discuss about our
good days
and that we had in Afghanistan together
I say for for my parents that one day we
will start our life together
Global News
Ottawa
next remembering Robbie Robertson I
speak to an oscar-winning filmmaker
about their remarkable relationship
welcome back Robbie Robertson had an
instrumental impact on the world of
Music the canadian-born musician died
last week after a battle with cancer but
his legacy lives on I spoke earlier with
Daniel Rohr the Canadian filmmaker won
an Oscar this year for his documentary
on Russian opposition leader Alexi
navalny and Roar credits Robertson with
launching his career
hey Daniel Jeff good to see you too man
how you doing good good obviously we
know you're now known as as Daniel Rohr
oscar-winning filmmakers some people use
that language yeah is that our
introduction doesn't sound natural to me
but before the Oscar before navalny yeah
you wrote you directed a film about
Robbie Roberts I was the Robbie
Robertson guy I think we're warmed up
I'm still I'm always going to be the
Robbie Robertson guy that that film was
so important and influential for me in
my career in my life and you know I was
so obviously so shocked when I heard the
news this this week that that Robbie
passed it came out of nowhere and when
you heard the news yeah what was the
what song did you listen to and why
that's a good question I think the first
song I Put on was unfaithful servant
which is just the saddest most beautiful
tender cry out
[Music]
you write direct this film but Robbie
Robertson yeah but at the time you were
what 23 years old relatively unknown so
how did that come to be I had always
been a fanatist I'd always been a huge
fan of the band it was in retrospect a
very compelling pitch I said I was like
Robbie you can hire some director who
has more credits who has a bigger
company who has bigger names so on and
so forth who will be making your film
along with five other films or you can
hire me and I will make this film like
my life depends on it I will give it
everything I have to give and Robbie
being an artist really appreciated and
understood the the the value of that in
order to make anything you have to be in
it with your whole heart and he got that
and I was and we were set off on our
merry way and so and what was it like
working with Robbie producing the film
you know Robbie likes he's a raconteur
he's a Storyteller he just like to sit
there and tell stories so it's very easy
to do your job you just say Robbie tell
me the story he's off this guitar was
the beginning of it all for me
here here but this is the I think this
is the crown jewel of his collection no
you know I've never held one of these is
it heavier than you thought you could
really I know yeah I'll always be
grateful that Robbie saw something in me
um and it I was really after the Oscars
last March
um you know it was it was meaningful to
me Robbie wrote to me and he's like
congrats kid I was right he said he was
like I was right about that kid from
Canada I was like
you were Robbie thanks so much man you
know he is very sweet and that meant a
lot to me and yeah I I think you grieve
differently when the person you've lost
leaves behind this body of work that
matters so much to you
it's like he's gone he is he is is now
on a different plane but his music will
live forever my mother was born and
raised in the sixth Nation Indian
reserve so in your film Robbie talks
about his mother yes indigenous grew up
six nations Grand River yeah uh and how
important was was that Community to him
and and to his music oh it was pivotal
Robbie is is so the nucleus of where he
came from his father was this sort of
like StreetWise Jewish kid from Toronto
his mother obviously grew up on Six
Nations and he was so the composite of
those two communities
um in a way that I you know as a Jewish
person I could really feel and sense
Robbie would spend his weekends in part
of his Summers uh in that community in
Six Nations and that's where he learned
to play the guitar for the first time
how do you think he would want to be
remembered I think Robbie would be very
happy if people sat around campfire
smoking a joint listening to music from
big pink for the rest of time so dream
big be ambitious if you want to play
music
aspire to the biggest stages in the
world you know like like if you step up
the bat aim for the Grand Slam and
that's how Robbie lived his life well
we're proud of you man I appreciate it
thank you so much thanks
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm Jeff Semple we leave
you with the Stellar scenes from last
night's preceded meteor shower the Earth
passing through a debris trail of an
ancient Comet creating hundreds of
shooting stars make a wish thanks for
watching have a great night
[Music]